[Música]
llegamos hasta partir hasta parís o para
hablar con nuestro periodista en la
capital francesa alize miguel cabrera él
es miguel muy buena mañana ya de viernes
terminamos esta semana la diplomacia
francesa está en huelga y es la segunda
protesta en la historia este premio que
se caracteriza lo y miguel por la
discreción pero cuáles son sus
reivindicaciones
saludos a raúl ya toda nuestra
teleaudiencia de la protesta en esencia
rechaza las reformas de la alta función
pública que implica a largo plazo la
desaparición de los diplomáticos como
profesionales de carrera los huelguistas
piden que se reanude el diálogo con el
ejecutivo para detener esta medida o
cambiarla ahora vamos a la reforma en sí
en resumen los diplomáticos asignados al
ministerio de relaciones exteriores
desarrollaban allí toda su carrera a
partir de 2023 no será así el cuerpo
diplomático desaparece y se crea uno
común el de los administradores del
estado que agruparía a los embajadores
consejeros diplomáticos y a los
funcionarios del resto de los
ministerios según los manifestantes
estos desprofesionaliza su trabajo
porque los puestos diplomáticos serían
ocupados por personas sin la formación
adecuada
actualmente hay que someterse a
concursos y exámenes para acceder al
ministerio de asuntos internacionales
otro señalamiento la reforma podría
conducir al nepotismo el amiguismo y la
politización de la alta función pública
los afectados acusan también a macrón de
amenazar con esta movida la influencia
del país en el exterior recordemos
francia cuenta con el tercer mayor
cuerpo diplomático del mundo después de
eeuu y china además esto sucede toda
esta huelga toda esta situación en medio
de la guerra en ucrania donde
precisamente el recurso a la diplomacia
es primordial raúl la amiga ya que
hablamos de las reformas del presidente
macro pasemos entonces a otra prioridad
de su gobierno el llamado regreso de las
matemáticas del sistema de enseñanza de
qué se trata esta iniciativa luis miguel
pues es una medida que consiste en
reinstaurar matemática como asignatura
obligatoria en el último año de la
educación secundaria superior macrón lo
prometió en su campaña para dar marcha
atrás a una reforma de su propio
gobierno que en 2019 eliminó totalmente
esa materia del curso terminal del liceo
consecuencia el nivel de dominio de esa
ciencia exacta por los estudiantes
franceses es el más bajo de europa
parece un asunto corriente pero es
cardinal para el desarrollo de la
economía del país tanto profesores como
economistas lo han estado alertando
además de ser un poco vergonzoso esto de
ser malo con las cuentas con los números
el presidente lo ve como un obstáculo
para que francia líder en innovación y
tecnología como el ambiciona el regreso
de las matemáticas fue un anuncio
particular dentro de otro más general el
programa la escuela del futuro un
experimento en torno a la cultura a los
idiomas el medio ambiente y la ciencia
que otorga a los directores de escuela
cierta independencia por ejemplo la de
elegir su propio plantel se trata de un
cambio radical en el modelo de educación
nacional y por tanto muy cuestionado los
sindicatos de educar temen que macro no
pretende transformar las escuelas en una
suma de pequeñas empresas y que se
profundiza en las desigualdades en
detrimento de los alumnos de los barrios
menos favorecidos